octobre 98 les programmes de radio morne
cérons dans les hauteurs de la commune
du laura sont suivies non seulement
parler leur ynwa mais également par
toute la martinique
les programmes radio donc sur la bande
fm sont est apprécié de tous mais pas
seulement également des animations sont
proposées par l'itu les animateurs de la
radio c'est justement le sujet qu'on
vous propose de suivre maintenant donc
flashback donc en octobre 98 ou les
caméras de martinique 1ère rfo à
l'époque était là on se retrouve juste
après c'était un des stands ont maté
kahn a toujours dit ce coupé les
communications mc martinique
josette d'année les vielles cazaux sont
les quatre animateurs permanents de rmc
radio demandes seront situés sur les
hauteurs de la commune du lorrain la
radio existe depuis 1983 elle est gérée
par une association l'ajc mc jeunesse
culturel demande serreau rmc aimé dans
la région du nord atlantique barrage est
là pour aider les associations du
lorrain déjà les associations du loret
et aussi les associations du grand nord
atlantique et nos rêves nos caresses
si genève qui reçoit artistes et
associations certaines d'entre elles ont
parfois des rendez vous hebdomadaire
avec les auditeurs comme l'association
force ouvrière consommateurs la faune se
sont déjà justement assez souvent les
gens qui ont des problèmes alors à la
forte ceux qui achètent des sacs parfums
roxy enfin communication entre autres
là d'où la musique haïtienne
traditionnelle et puis la musique anglo
saxonne disque américaine est aussi un
française une offre médicale que l'on
retrouve un peu partout dans la
trentaine de radios en martinique
difficile donc de concurrencer celles du
centre abreuver de pub dans le nord
atlantique c'est la vache maigre du côté
des annonceurs retour en 2010 est de nos
jours et il s'en est passé des choses
pour radio morneau cérons puisqu'elle a
d'abord perdu sedan l'a ensuite elle a
perdu sa fréquence mais elle n'a pas
perdu cette envie de diffusion donc
c'est sur le web qu'en 2017
et bien cette radio diffuse ses
programmes alors ne reviendra pas sur
toutes les raisons qui ont fait que vous
avez perdu cette fréquence donc vous
émettez sur le web comment ça se passe
exactement
donc ça se passe très bien puisque c'est
poisson à la braise ethnologie donc il
faut également s'adapter puisque on sait
aujourd'hui il ya plus de radios qui
émettent sur le rêve de nouvelles
expériences mais c'est vrai qu'il des
pleins peu à nos auditeurs qui avait
comme pour la peau habitude de nous
écouter donc via les faux la fréquence
donc là nous sommes en train de
l'attendre nouvelles fréquences du csa
alors vous êtes moins interactifs là on
est en salle de montage ou des
programmes par exemple des défilés du
carnaval de la ville du lorrain sont en
train d'être monté pour être diffusée
sur le web
ensuite il ya aussi quand même des
émissions interactives sur le web avec
sur lesquels des auditeurs peuvent
peuvent intervenir
oui donc au cvec via notre page facebook
ou d'autres sites internet donc les gens
peuvent réagir en option ces différentes
sur différents supports
effectivement laissé des messages et il
a écouté et nous avons aussi adapté donc
le programme radio au niveau de la
télévision donc au niveau de la route
et puis on se pose souvent la question
maintenant quels sont les moyens
d'exister d'une dune ras d'une radio
diffusée sur le web à l'heure actuelle
de la pub de la publicité c'est pas
évident dans notre secteur
un peu north atlantic donc un peu avec
des commerçants qui ont la peine d'en de
la peine à pouvoir joindre les deux
bouts et c'est pas évident alors merci
gérard et puis surtout on vous souhaite
d'obtenir cette fameuse fréquence que
vous réclamez